[Music]
raus what were your expectations last
night I thought it'd be a close game dan
and I thought at the end that Brady and
Belichick would be the better bet to go
with and Dan Quinn and Matt Ryan late
which proved to be the case but not
nearly how I thought it would go down I
mean for three quarters I don't know if
the Patriots were in slow motion or the
Falcons were in fast forward but the
Patriots were getting absolutely killed
that the Falcons look like the younger
faster better team I still cannot
believe that that happened and if I'm a
Falcons player today I am sick and I
can't imagine getting over this for a
long long time
what is half-time like in the Patriots
locker room probably pretty businesslike
at that point you know it's 21 3 which
isn't that unreasonable and if you
noticed and I know everybody was
tweeting it last night but you know
there first of all the other Super Bowls
they never scored in the first quarter
so I think it's pretty calm relatively
speaking here's what we need to do to
change it and the one thing I always
tell people Dan I wasn't in New England
that long I was there parts of two
seasons but when you have Brady as your
quarterback you still always think
you're gonna win like you you always
believe until the game's over that
you're gonna win because you've got the
guy and I was on plenty of teams where
we didn't have the guy and we knew that
too it just I can't tell you how much it
does for the confidence or really lack
thereof and whether it's conscious or
subconscious among teammates when you
have that guy or you don't explain to me
as a former offensive lineman the
Patriots offensive line was a whole lot
better boarding on great in the 3rd
certainly fourth quarter in overtime
whereas they were getting manhandled by
the same pass rush they're not bringing
any extra people and why was New
England's offensive line so much better
in the second half than the first half I
think it's two things primarily I think
Brady was doing a better job but getting
rid of the pole
all faster if you notice there was a
bunch of times where his receivers
couldn't get open I mean they were like
glue and then even in the second half
when he was getting rid of the ball and
they were getting open there was a bunch
of drops I think Edelman had to
I know Hogan had one or two but more
than anything else and I told people
this Dan I had nine offensive line
coaches when I was in the NFL but Dante
Starr Nekia who they got out of
retirement this year he had by far the
toughest individual periods I was never
a part of every practice I felt like I
might throw up because that's how hard
it was and that's how much we were
running so people I thought the high
school kids college kids the heaviest
guy we had was Logan maggots at 3:12 we
were all lean and mean between 300 and
308 and it looked to me like they were
just in much better shape than the
Falcon and when you're gonna have 92
plays like that the D lineman especially
it's the most tiring position in sports
they're just gonna run out of gas and
they did I also look at the play calling
I've been banging on this all day long
the fourth quarter I just I don't
understand why you're not using the
clock even on a third and one with eight
minutes to go and I know the end result
was Hightower with the strip sack which
I do think changed the game if you get
to four and a half minutes Ross you're
at the 22 yard line first first down and
you're up by eight I I don't understand
why you're not running the clock and
make you know there's only so much time
in a game and if Brady doesn't have any
time left he's not beating you I I just
don't underst
the logic of throwing the football with
four minutes to go up eight at the 22
yard line
I really can't and I even have a problem
I mean dad so many times they snap the
ball late in the third quarter or the
fourth quarter with 10 or 15 seconds on
the play clock yeah I just mentioned
they yeah I didn't understand that Oh
what are you doing and then the real
problem I can always live with the other
play the Hightower play you mentioned
third and one passing but when you're
averaging over secure to carry at that
point why are you in the shotgun when
you're throwing like what why is it not
a play-action pass it
extremely frustrating that's why I feel
so bad for the Falcons players and their
fans now I will say this you know as
players were supposed to take personal
accountability responsibility Devonta
Freeman have to pick up Hightower Ryan
has to get the ball out of his hands
Matt Ryan can't take the next sack that
he took one second down Jake Matthews
can't hold but you're a thousand percent
correct I think Dan Quinn is that
hands-off offensively that he just lets
Kyle Shanghai and do his thing and it's
like Kyle Shanahan did not realize the
game situation if they run it three
times kick a field goal they're up 11
less than four minutes left the odd that
the Patriots get touchdown two-point
conversion onside kick and field goal
are minimal at that point it's a comedy
of errors that cost the Falcon 2
championship and and just mind
bogglingly bat you know we always want
to give battle check credit and we
should and he deserves it but that's
just terrible coaching on the other side
he's Ross Tucker host of the Ross Tucker
football podcast former NFL lineman
joining us Dan Patrick show I know we
haven't had overtime in the Superbowl
until last night and they'll probably be
a push to overhaul overtime now that
we've had the Patriots winning the way
they did have any problem with overtime
in the playoffs no I always go the other
way I mean you think about it the
Falcons already played over 80 snaps at
that point I never talked with a guy Dan
when I was playing or afterwards they
had a problem with sudden-death so and
I'm sitting there sitting next to my
wife last night and she's like okay so
what happens now I said well whoever
scores first you know it doesn't if they
get a touchdown they went I don't know
why we made it more confusing than it
had to be and quite frankly I know that
there's some sentiment and Mike Florio
propofol tongs as a buddy of ours feels
that way Peter King that they should
both get a chance why does it Falcon
deserve a chance there I mean they blew
like five chances in the third reserve
another chip I don't want to watch them
again they blew it I don't need to see
them again
I like the
it ended with Brady scoring and it ended
up being sudden that you never to feel
cool though
I'm fine with that I liked the old
sudden-death
I don't like there's a reason why was
there's three or four games and what's
that what there were ties last year yeah
not a fan of that Russ
thank you Greg talk to you thanks for
all your contributions during the
football season and we'll talk soon Ross
Tucker host of the rock soccer football
podcast and former offensive lineman in
the NFL the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
[Music]